hi and welcome to cloud on air live
webinars from the Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday
my name is leap tea Shrivastav and I'll
be talking about cloud spanner you can
ask me questions any time on the
platform and we have Googlers on the
standby that will take the questions
give them to me - - for me to answer
today's webinar is kind of special
because it's called stumped the pros
does Google Cloud go sorry Google Cloud
spinner go faster than the speed of
light another I fake use so your mission
today if you choose to accept it is to
ask me anything and see if I can answer
them about Google Cloud spanner so let's
get started so to begin with I just want
to give a quick overview of cloud
spanner just to give you a little bit of
time to see what clever questions you
can come up with and we will go into Q&A
straight after that so what is cloud
spanner so cloud spanner is GCP Google
cloud platforms enterprise-grade
globally distributed and strongly
consistent distributed database system
and it's built specifically for the
cloud to combine the benefits of both
relational database structure and
non-relational horizontal scale now what
did that mean so essentially we've
combined the relational semantics of
schemas asset transactions and sequel as
well as the horizontal scale and
availability of no sequel systems into
one fully managed and easy to use
relational database service what that
means is you don't have to do any more
trained trade-offs or tuning so
basically you don't have to make the
decision of do I abandon relational
semantics to get scale or do I abandon
scale to get the the relation semantics
cuz I can't actually do without sort of
sequel and transactions across rows and
end tables with spanner you get the best
of both so you can basically have you
know high availability we actually offer
ninety-nine point
five nines of availability SLA for a
multi region configuration and all of
this is packaged up into one easy-to-use
system so in terms of Management because
we are a fully managed system what that
means is you don't have to have the
burden and the overhead of constantly
worrying about keeping your database up
and running right in fact it takes four
clicks for you to even spin up a
globally distributed database you can go
to our cloud console you can just you
know create an instance create a
database create a schema and you're good
to go so what that means is you don't
have to worry about oh my gosh if I have
to create an index like do I have to
bring down the database if I have to add
a table to have to bring down the
database there isn't any main management
or maintenance windows that you have to
worry about because all of that is taken
care of by us and our fantastic every
team in the background and you just
worry about your database and getting
the most out of it because we combine
relational semantics with scale what
that means is that you get to launch
apps faster because you don't have to
ever worry about learning a new language
we have an C sequel 2011 compliant
sequel we have schemas just like any
other relational database that you're
used to we have sort of security and
high availability built into the system
so you don't have to there are not sort
of nickel and dime add-ons that you have
to pay for extra they just come part of
the package and all of that kind of gets
offered to you so that you and your
developers can you know create the best
database that you want on top of our
solution all of this by the way is given
to you with strong consistency
cloud spanner is always strongly
consistent right there isn't any sort of
which consistency do I need to choose to
get the best out of my system right
there is you always get strongly
consistent data which means you don't
have to worry about it you don't have to
do cross shard transactions any of that
like it because it's scalable it you get
all of that built into the system and
you never have to worry about
inconsistent incorrect inaccurate data
which means you can
just build your application on top of
your strongly consistent a cloud span a
database and you can just go right you
never have to think about Reap lat
forming or you know really crazy bugs
because of consistency semantics that
are not met or not the way you expected
them to be off your data which means
you're always always getting consistent
data and always able to create the best
database get the best database semantics
on and build the best applications as
fast as you want and you can just launch
and go so as I said earlier today's
challenge is to ask me anything about
cloud spanner and and let's have a
discussion about distributed systems and
how we made cloud spanner possible and
available to all of you out there stay
tuned for the live Q&A we'll be back in
less than a minute
you
welcome back and let's get started with
our Q&A so the first question we have is
is cloud spanning a drop-in replacement
for other relational databases so it is
a relational database cloud spanner is
but it's also horizontally scalable what
that means is you can use your schemas
especially for simple relational schemas
like it should be a complete like
transformation back into cloud spanner
right we have DDL statements we have
joins we have you know all that stuff so
it shouldn't be a problem to translate
however and this is true if you've ever
used a relational database each database
has its own quirks and each database
requires some massaging especially for
the more complicated data sets and the
more complicated data types so in
general I don't anticipate any problem
it's it's taking your relational
database and moving it to spanner
but there's always caveats on on you
know depending on the data set and the
data type the one interesting thing
about cloud spanner is that because it
offers what we call interleave
statements which is essentially a pre
join of your tables it actually allows
you to structure within a relational
database hierarchical data sets and you
can actually pre join two tables by
putting into leaf clauses in so you can
do fast scans so you can think about it
as instead of having to do a join at
every query time for data that is
queried together very often you can
actually inter leave and join
predetermine the the data set is joined
and then clouds manner can take that as
a hint you like quickly scan over a
bunch of data
so hopefully that answer that the next
question we have is how do you guarantee
four nines and five nines of
availability that's a great question
so just to recap cloud spanner offers
four lines of availability for our
regional instances and five nines for
our multi regional instances so if you
if you look at GC p GC p zones itself by
themselves offer three nines of
availability per zone and as you may
know cloud spanner is replicated within
threes
for the regional instance and across
three regions and at least five zones
for the multi region configurations and
multigon conversions differs so it could
be all the way up to nine zones so the
idea is you know if you really look at
the probabilities even for the regional
instance if you sort of multiply out the
probabilities for 99.99 across three
zones that's a lot of nights but we know
that you know all the failures aren't
independent because for example you know
within a region there is some
geographical correlations right like if
a mutual Sykes or something like that so
keeping that realistic we we offer the
four 9s for the regional and in the
multi region case because you know we
have actually distributed the database
across multiple regions as I said at
least three that means we are we are
taking care of not having Geographic
correlated faults so in that case you
know we can remove one element of sort
of risk and we can offer you up to five
nines I hope that made sense our next
question is I read about interleaved
tables
what's the advantage of that so I think
I mentioned that in the first question
actually
but basically what the interleave
statement in our DDL language is is a
hint to spanner to say that you will
query these two data sets very often
together right so if you have a let's
say you have a table albums and other
table singers and you're you're because
you're running that their music service
for each album for each user you have
multiple albums and multiple singers
right so you you constantly query for it
or singer all their albums which means
you're gonna you know traditional sense
you will have to do a join of singers
and albums and then produce the results
in spanners case if you say interleave
albums in singers what that means is
that the system spanner itself will pre
join the data set and store it
such that when you actually query them
together it'll just do a fast scan which
means you avoid the penalty
so our next question is if I start with
a single region is it possible to scale
to multi region easily so currently the
way we expect customers to do it is to
take a export of their cloud spano
database and then import it into a multi
region configuration we hope that in the
future we'll have a easy solution for
you to have this as a managed thing so
you can just sort of tell spanner hey I
want to move this database from this
single region into a multi version
configuration and you can specify both
and we should have be able to do that
but that's not currently what we offer
so our next question is is there a
documented migration path from cloud
sequel to cloud spanner so there isn't a
documented path but we do have customer
use cases of how they've done it so you
know Quizlet for example is a online
test study application and they've
actually migrated from there multiple i
can't say how many but multiple cloud
sequel shards into one cloud spanish
database and they've written a a case
study on it that you can find online is
linked from our Doc's actually so you
can look at that we have other such use
cases and stories as well again we hope
to have solutions papers for customers
to be able to do this and they are
coming shortly but as of right now you
should be able to find information based
on the customer case studies next um
when wouldn't you choose cloud spanner
over cloud sequel hmm that's an
interesting question so there are
obviously two use cases one is if you've
already been using cloud sequel and
you've had to go to the sharded solution
for cloud Siebel because you know your
data set group or your you know your
application got really successful and
you have more QPS more queries coming in
that you know your one box cloud sequel
or even any my sequel system can offer
them in that case sort of cloud spanner
is an obvious choice because you don't
have to give up your wonderful sequel
and relational semantics to be able to
deal with the scale which is what you
would had to do
if you sort of chose a scalable solution
which was no sequel and so you can just
take your your cloud sequel shards and
then migrate over to cloud spanner and
then never have to worry about real
platforming again in terms of if you're
starting out with a new Greenfield
application again if you expect to be
growing very quickly in both either in
terms of data set or you know app QPS or
a combination if you start with cloud
spanner you never have to read platform
right so you have the ability to build
the system once and then keep it growing
and and never have to worry about sort
of maintenance and and the hazards of oh
you know my box fell over because the
granted memory or not look those kinds
of things however if you're comfortable
with cloud sequel and you you know you
don't think you need any of the high
availability or management or you know
scalability or relational semantics of
clouds banner then you know if you're
happy with the cloud sequel you've
already been building the applications
on it you don't expect the data set to
grow or the QPS to learn as I said you
don't expect to be you've already got
all the maintenance pieces in place and
management pieces in place then you know
by all means if you're happy with cloud
people please continue to use it um next
can I explain how clouds burn of
replicas work in the background does the
spanner use synchronous replication yes
it does use synchronous replication and
I have a few slides here that can
basically walk us through this but
basically as I mentioned cloud spanner
is synchronously replicated under the
cover so you will only ever have to deal
with one database and one database
endpoint you never have to worry about
which replicas you need to talk to or
rebalance over replicas none of that
right that's just completely hidden from
from you you have to just worry about
talking to your database so we have a
few slides here as I said let's talk
about the regional configuration first
because it's the simplest to talk about
so as you can see here we've taken one
regional cloud spanner insta
which has three replicas as I mentioned
earlier these three replicas are in
three different GCP zones within a given
region we've chosen a European region in
this case but it could be any GCP region
and as you can see there are three
readwrite replicas of the database
within this region in the multi region
case things get a little bit more
complicated but the original idea
remains the same which is that you have
multiple replicas across multiple
different GCP regions across multiple
different DCP zones within those regions
so we have three regions in the US in
this particular configuration this is
one of the configurations we actually
offer it's our name
you are Asia one region which is
basically a global region that's our
global configuration so what that means
is we have the right quorum in the US
split across or spread across three
different US GCP regions and an Asia
region with two asia regions each having
read-only replicas and then a european
set which has two replicas both in
different GCP regions so what that means
is we've basically distributed the data
across different geographic locations to
I remove the or reduce the probability
of correlative faults due to natural or
Geographic issues so as you can see here
there are nine replicas spread across
five different sorry seven different GCP
regions now what does that mean in terms
of how you interact with cloud spanner
so you have one cloud spanner instance
which has all these replicas of the
databases in that instance you can have
more than one database if you wanted an
instance right depending on on your use
case and each of these databases have
multiple tables right and they go to
multiple splits of the database
so what that means is because so Clark
spanner is a sharded synchronously
replicated database and each database is
actually has a full copy of the data
across the multiple replicas which means
all the tables and all the data is
stored in all the different regions
fully and the data is split across
multiple what we call it splits to allow
it to spread over multiple different
nodes clouds banner nodes to again
reduce the chances of a single failure
bringing down the whole system right so
we are parallelizing and splitting and
sharding all of which is happening
automatically so as we talked about
there are multiple zones and an update
if an update comes in basically we use
Paxos to replicate the data and get
consensus into committing a right so in
this case you know there's an update
that comes in for table 1 and table 2
let's say you want to do an insert
across both tables and then the paxos
protocol we have which is by the way the
protocol that we wrote ourselves to
optimize it's not the open source box
with protocol we have our own optimized
version of it to again give us the the
performance and high availability that
we've talked about so much so basically
an update comes in we use Paxos to
commit the write across all replicas and
by the time you get the the
acknowledgement back of the write so if
the commit succeeds you are guaranteed
that the data has been persisted and you
can query it as soon as you get the
commit back so let's move on to other
questions here hopefully that helped and
I can go into it in more detail if folks
are interested so going back to our
question set um is there a doc sorry I
lost my train of thought um
right ok how does cloud spanner ensure
that there isn't a single point of
failure so I think I'd covered some of
this in our discussion so far which is
that cloud spanner is both replicated
across multiple zones and multiple
CP reagent it's also sharded within a
zone right so zone is where a replica a
full copy of the clock span and database
exists and now it's not one monolithic
structure right it's sharted and each
shard is put on one of the multiple
nodes that you you know a sign for
clouds banner so because of the sharding
and because of the replication you can
we can guarantee that there isn't a
single point of failure right because if
even if one node goes down which I'll
get into a minute of what happens in
case of failure but even if one node
goes down in there multiple nodes the
other nodes are up and running to serve
data now I'm talking about one of the
multiple zones right so in one zone if
you have ten nodes and one goes down
then at most that 1/10 at most 1/10 of
data is supposed to be unavailable but
because we are also replicated across
zones if the client notices that one
node that you it was talking to goes
down it will actually just contact the
other regions with the same data so from
the client or the customer view point
you actually don't even notice this on
top of which we're constantly monitoring
the health of our nodes and off the
system overall all different aspects of
it and so we're constantly rebalancing
and recharging these these nodes and the
data on them right so in fact the sort
of failure scenario isn't really a huge
deal because we're constantly already
automatically changing the data set and
where it resides in which nodes it sits
on so it's not a sort of one-time event
where something happened and now you
have a huge outage or a blip because the
the one or two nodes fell down right if
the whole thing is just sort of
automatically managed for you so you as
a cloud spanner user don't even notice
that there in most cases that one or two
notes went down this is actually one of
the reasons why we say that you know the
SLA is offered for at least three nodes
in an instance because as you can see if
you have only one node and that will
know when down then yes you
your data is at risk even though there
are two other replicas that you can talk
to but in the case of three nodes that
you get for a production instance
they're actually three times three in
the regional case so nine nodes that can
serve your data and in a given point in
time so that and a bunch of other sort
of optimizations that we've made you
know including the GCP Network and the
the full TCP stack allow us to have the
no single point of failure because
they're a bunch of virtualized
components all of which are sort of
constantly rebalancing and healing
moving on to our next question from the
audience when when I consider spanner /
BigTable right question um so spanner is
a relational database I think that's the
first thing you need to think about when
you're when you're choosing which sort
of data storage system you need to use
for your data set right do you want a
relational database with sequel with
schemas with high availability with
cross sort of globally available
distributed database or or I do not need
that right BigTable is great for sort of
scalability aspect and for doing a bunch
of you know high throughput reads and
writes such as you know like if you have
time to use data etc there's a lot of
information on you know BigTable use
cases but the point is it's not a sequel
database right it's a no sequel database
it's horizontally scalable and has a lot
of great properties but it doesn't offer
you DDL or cross row across region asset
transactions it doesn't offer you sequel
and it doesn't offer you schemas with
DDL statements the next audience
question how many nodes can spanner grow
to how many notes can you buy so spanner
is sort of I don't want to say use the
word infinitely scalable but it's
designed to be scalable - seriously -
petabytes of data and hundreds upon
hundreds of nodes right so really the
the
real question is what is the capacity of
the the cluster or the data center that
you are buying spanner in really at some
level right and and how many how much
money to spend to buy spanner nodes but
the technology inherently is meant to be
scalable about providing asset
transactions which is what makes it so
cool and why I'm so excited about it
and I can tell you from some of our
internal use cases that you know scaling
to petabytes of data and the associated
sort of compute power required is really
not a problem next question I was
wondering how long this will take to
come up does cloud sprout to break the
cap theorem absolutely not
so the cap theorem is about you know
maintaining availability in the face of
partition right and maintaining
consistency in the face of partitions
and the way cloud spanner is able to
achieve availability while having sort
of partitioned and achieved strong
consistency in the face of partitions is
because twofold one the entire stack is
designed to have not a single point of
failure as we talked about right so it's
got you know sharding replication
synchronous replication and charting
built-in and we again use the Paxos
protocol which means that we don't have
to as long as we have a majority we can
continue to write and as long as we have
at least one replicas available we can
actually continue to read for a long
time um there's a there's a really great
paper written by Eric Brewer who's the
the author of the cap theorem who's
talked about sort of cap cap theorem and
spanner and what that means that I
encourage anybody who's interested to go
to read it it describes all of these
things in much more detail it's on our
website cloud.google.com spanner and to
round out that thought so the the other
reason we can do this is because of
Gould networking right so we have put a
lot of thought and careful
instrumentation of our networks to make
sure that you know we can continue to
operate you know across
multiple types of network failures and
we have a bunch of redundancy and you
know as I said health checking and
health monitoring built in to reroute
traffic if we notice slowdown somewhere
or if we notice sort of you know some
pads are blocked then we can sort of
reroute all this happening automatically
and the system sort of taking care of
making sure that we can have
availability of networks right so the
Google networking as well as the the
spanner stack both allow us to sort of
push the limits of cap theorem as I
talked about but yes I said there's more
a lot more detail in the cap theorem and
spanner paper that I encourage you guys
to read next question how well does it
perform over large physical geographies
I you know well is a very interesting
term so so you can do you know acid
consistent transactions across rows
across regions across data centers
across continents with spanner right and
you can do them with low latency so that
you can run mission-critical
applications on spanner and some of it
is to do with the fact that as I
mentioned you know the Google networking
is fabulous and you know we can sort of
the cloud spanner called basically this
the cloud spanner client puts any sort
of incoming requests on to the Google
network as quickly as possible so that
it can be routed to the correct cloud
spanner zone to be served right and
there is intelligence built in so that
we can choose the closest replica or get
the fastest response right so in terms
of you know performance I think is where
you're getting to here um and so let me
talk about some of that so basically in
the multi region instance that we talked
about earlier that I showed a slide on
that we have you know us quorum and read
replicas in Europe and Asia the way to
think about it is that for a multi
region cloud spanner instance you're
trading off right latency for read
latency
right so you want to have fast reads
everywhere and you can tolerate a little
bit of slowness for rights in a
particular region so what that means but
but by slowness I'm not talking about
you know seconds and and minutes and
none of that right like what I'm talking
about is for example if you have a write
coming in from Asia in this multi region
configuration then you know we expect
because of speed of light which we have
in you know solved yet or we don't go
fast in the speed of light yet you know
a call for manager will take sort of 300
milliseconds round-trip time right 350
maybe so there is bad round-trip time
that you have to take into account for
latency overwrite that comes in from
Asia for a u.s. quorum however if you
want to do a read from Asia you know the
cloud spanner client is smart enough to
go to that replica that's closest to it
in Asia for the type of reads that you
use and give you a response and you know
within a region we expect sort of you
know why millisecond response depending
on the type of reads that you have again
these are all very sort of hand wavy
numbers because it really depends on the
type of read you're doing and the amount
of data you're reading or writing right
like if you're writing 10 gigs of data
then it's gonna take time
right but the processing times for
spanner itself we we have tried to
optimize this as much as possible and we
use as I said again the little network
which is you know highly optimized
so you know RT T's round-trip times are
you know much lower than what you would
get in on the general internet you know
in terms of traffic
hopefully that answer that question um
next question how these cloud spanner
managed apart from the Google console
does it have a cloud shell or cloud SDK
yes absolutely absolutely
we offer the UI obviously cloud console
we have a G cloud SDK that has cloud
spanner and all the commands are there
for it and yeah so we have a CLI and of
course we have the API that you can code
to directly if you so choose in fact
some of our customers wanted to write
libraries apart from the civil languages
that we had or they want to sort of
instrument it their own way or wanted to
use rest so we offer G RPC
client libraries that you can use and
that take care of a bunch of sort of
maintenance tasks and things like that
like you know transaction retries for
example and we offer a REST API as well
so that you can use it if you have
applications that must use rest then you
can you know code directly or write your
own client library for the rest command
as well and all of this is by the way
available on our on our documentation on
our site so you can again go to
cloud.google.com slash span or slash
docs and you should have a whole
plethora of documentation there next
question is it recommended to use cash
engines like memcache to your Redis with
cloud spanner or is it not necessary
great question you know this is one of
those things that depends there are a
lot of distributed systems answers that
are it depends so it depends on the kind
of application you have and the Layton
sees that it requires right so in most
cases cloud spanners latencies are good
enough where you can directly query the
the database itself and you know and of
course we we cache hot data sets in
memory obviously so you know a lot of
that is taking care of my cloud fan
itself but if you have sort of you know
large data sets or you know data sets
that are sort of always being read and
you really you know like a gaming thing
if you if you have a gaming app and
there's a bunch of users that are
playing up games together and they all
need to query some sort of game state
that is not really changing that often
right you need to flush it once in a
while back to the back end but mostly it
needs to be served very fast right like
sub-millisecond or whatever then you can
put a cache in front of your cost
metadata base memcache to your register
your choice and then serve it from there
and it then most of the QPS is kind of
like handled by the cache and you know
once in a while if there is some state
change in the game then you can flush it
back to the - spanner and then reload
the cache right and all of that can of
course because because the database
itself is mission-critical is low
latency you can you know expect that
that the cache refreshes don't take that
long and you can sort of
cycle them based on you know your QPS
cycles and things like that I hope that
answered that um next question what
control do I have over how the database
works so again this is sort of I can
take this so many ways um you know
you've set up your database with your
schema so there is that right you
control how the schema works we in terms
of introspection tooling if that's what
you're asking you know we have a few
introspection tools already and there
are a bunch more that are on in the
works that will be coming out later this
year but the first introspection tooling
that we have is you know our query plan
visualization that we have in the cloud
console so what you can do is you can
run a sequel query you can see how the
query is performing right whether
they're a table joint a sari table scans
that you didn't expect etc you know
whether it's doing a back door with
another table that you didn't expect so
you can look at the query plans and and
figure out you know whether your query
is performing the way you expected it to
and you can make adjustments based on
that as I said there is a bunch of other
tooling that's coming up you know we
have debug tokens that we will sort of
release soon we have you know sort of a
bunch of things to give you
introspection into the database of how
the queries are performing instead of in
in terms of sorry
in terms of the database itself right we
offer sort of QPS metrics to see what
the throughput of your database looks
like we have offer a sort of you know
how many megabytes per second it's
getting and how many QPS it's getting
and responding with we also obviously
show you the CPU utilization of your
database because that's one of the key
metrics that you need in order to figure
out whether you want to add more nodes
or not and we offer storage metrics
right so all of these metrics are also
available through start driver and we
have a landing page for stack driver
where you can see all these metrics
combined and if you want to set alerts
on any of these metrics you can do so
and see them on the cloud spanner
console right so
so we are trying to offer you as much of
an integrated solution as possible now
again there are those who've been used
to sort of tinkering with every aspect
of the database and for them you know
there is some control issue that you
will have to give up because it is a
managed service the whole point is you
don't have to worry about how the
database works you just have to worry
about sort of whether your database is
looking like or performing the way you
expect it to right whether your schema
is performing the way it's expected to
you right whether you need to optimize
your schema or not I mean the rest of it
you kind of have to sort of just let
others deal with it right you never have
to another way to think about it right
is you never have to wake up at 3:00 in
the morning from a pager because you
know a node fell over right or you were
running out of storage capacity right we
auto-scale storage for example so you
never have to worry about that right and
the only thing you really need to sort
of think about is what is your compute
utilization and do you need to increase
compute depending on whether you know
your your new app has become really
popular so you add nodes which by the
way you go to the console you change a
number in a in a field and voila like
you know within a matter of seconds you
like whew maybe two or three seconds you
get new nodes right and the same thing
you can actually reduce nodes as well
just by changing a number so so the idea
is you don't have to worry about
managing or maintaining the database the
idea is you leave the worrying to us you
know leave the pagers to us and you just
have a happy running app on your
database next what happens in the event
of a network failure so I think we
talked about this a lot it depends on
where the network failure is if you're
talking about network failure between
cloud spanner zones or regions then as I
said in the regional case you have three
zones which means if there's a network
failure between one of the from one of
the zones to the others then first of
all it's it's Google's problem to repair
the network not yours right second of
all the other two replicas are up and
running as I talked about right so they
can serve your data quite happily
without worrying about the third zone
being down and by the way because
they're a bunch of automatic things in
place and because we have a 24-hour a
sorry team that's managing and
maintaining these these cloud spatter
instances and databases within them you
know somebody will be I guarantee you
somebody will be looking at this problem
and trying to get the system back online
as quick for that zone back online
because the rest of the zones are
available and to you the clouds fan our
instance and databases within it are
available but somebody's gonna look at
it and like try to bring it back online
GCP and Google's philosophy actually is
to used to do root cause analysis later
to get the system up and running to fix
the problem first and then go and do
debugging later right sorry good close
analysis later so that's the one thing
in the multi region case you know
multiply it out right there's so many
more replicas that you can serve the day
or from that it you know a single
network failure a single zone in single
entire zone failure actually has almost
no effect on you and your ability to
serve data from cloud spanner
hopefully they answer that next question
can I dig Tate where my data is stored
so you can absolutely choose the cloud
spanner configuration and we put your
database in the instance in which you've
chosen it to be which means within the
configuration within which you've chosen
to put your instance right so in the
original case if you choose u.s. central
one or you west one or Asia East one for
your cloud spanner instance then you
know your entire database which means
all your compute and all your storage is
stored within that region in the multi
region case right depending again on the
multi region configuration you choose
and by the way we tell you which regions
are going to be used in that
multi-region configuration so you are
aware of which regions which data
centers essentially the data is in which
means which country or geography or city
it's in so you have that level of
control but no you can
pick if you want to pick exactly which
zone exactly which cluster your data is
in then no right that defeats the point
of having a managed database service
because you then have to worry about
what happens at the zone goes down or
what happens if the storage is not
available in that zone right so you
don't have to worry about that if a zone
goes down we move your data let's say to
a different zone what happens if it you
know any of those scenarios happen we
take care of that situation for you and
you just talk to one database endpoint
and continue to function next question
how do i migrate from other relational
databases great question so right now as
I said if you have a simple schema it
should be fairly simple to sort of take
that schema and translate it into a
cloud spanner VDL DDL language you and
into a cloud spanner it's schema and
then write data into it right I know
it's a huge and manual process and I
totally understand that we are working
on various ways for our customers to
make this easier for them the the the
first thing we're working on is sort of
an import/export functionality that that
should be around in the next quarter or
so that allows you to take you know
filed in a GCS bucket and import them
into spanner like Avro files for example
that you can take a dump of your
database put them in Avro put them in a
GCS bucket and then import them into
cloud spanner right you can specify the
schema and then you know at least the
data migration piece is taken care of
for you over time we also are working on
simple push-button tooling so that you
know especially for as I said simple
schemas that don't require too much sort
of conflict resolution you can just sort
of do a simple migration path into cloud
spanner so we are definitely thinking
about that and wanting to make this an
easy solution for all of our customers
so please hang in there and our last
question wow we have a last question
what makes cloud spanner
mission-critical
so
good question the point of a
mission-critical data database is that
it's highly available its performant and
allows you to focus on delivering value
to your customers without having to
worry about database management
maintenance availability replication and
sort of brittle application code that
will constantly break because you know
the store or the strong consistency and
all those kinds of semantics are not
being met right there aren't asset
transactions etc so cloud spanner gives
you and we've talked about a bunch of
these things right like cloud spanner
gives you high performance high
availability built in replication built
in security so then you can run your
absolutely sort of business critical
applications on spanner right business
critical is banks in health care and
gaming and all of these sort of various
scenarios in which you know your
business depends on your data we take
that very seriously right we've been
running Google's business critical data
on spanner for multiple multiple years
and we are basically sort of with that
experience saying that you can with
peace of mind put your business critical
data on spanner and then you don't have
to worry about the database its
availability and the ability to use it
across multiple regions geographies and
continents so with that I think we're
out of time if there any more questions
I'm happy to answer them sort of on the
platform but I hope you enjoyed this
session and I hope some of the questions
were answered I have to say I wasn't
stumped so far but there were really
good questions so maybe we'll do this
again but stay tuned in the meantime for
the next session coming to you live from
Google New York office in a bit thank
you